bonjour à tous alors merci d'être là
pour ce point presse que philippe juvin
et moi tenons nous serons rejoints tout
à l'heure par le député maire d'arcachon
yves foulon qui viendra vous présenter
les propositions des républicains en
matière de tourisme et de politique
d'attractivité de notre pays
un mot d'abord sur l'agenda de la
semaine extrêmement dense
l'afld au plan international et national
demain le président des républicains et
philippe lui en parler se rendre à
berlin pour une journée extrêmement
importante qui lui permettra notamment
de rencontrer la chancelière d'allemagne
angela merkel le soir nous tiendrons
avec eric woerth ici rendez vous du
projet sur le thème des entreprises les
entreprises au coeur de la puissance et
du rayonnement de la france mercredi
matin le matin donc les républicains
tiendront temps de travail consacrée aux
institutions publiques aux institutions
politiques
ça sera conclue par un discours du
président à à midi c'est comme vous le
savez une nouvelle brique du projet de
gouvernement des républicains qui sera
présenté le 2 juillet lors du conseil
national à 17 heures mercredi olivier
dassault en sa qualité de président du
comité des entrepreneurs des
républicains remettra au président
sarkozy un livre blanc le livre blanc de
génération entreprises entrepreneurs
associés et à 19 heures nous aurons un
autre rendez vous du projet animé par
eric woerth
autour du thème du numérique et de
l'innovation numérique et innovation
comment la france peut devenir une
grande puissance
jeudi le président de la république 1 se
rendra à arcachon où il tiendra une
réunion publique et dimanche
nicolas sarkozy sera en ille et vilaine
en bretagne donc à l'invitation de la
fédération départementale des
républicains d'ille et vilaine philippe
pour l'agenda berlinois oui donc nicolas
sarkozy comme tu l'as dit se rend à
berlin où il déjeunera avec la
chancelière merkel avant de participer à
une séance d'ouverture du conseil
économique d'une des principales
organisations patronales allemande qui
est liée à la ddt cd ou et après le
déjeuner avec la chancelière qu'il faut
aussi lié à ces visites international
ila quand vous le savez vu le président
poutine la semaine dernière ce qui
montre que notre parti et se préoccupe
de la place de la france dans le monde
et de son poids d'un concert des nations
et que le président sarkozy reste un
interlocuteur de poids pour les
gouvernements étrangers
le président de notre mouvement
participera à la session d'ouverture
consacrée au futur de l'europe
organisées par la villa wirtschaft rate
qui est ce fameux conseil économique
proche de la cd ou avec wolfhound chars
bleus avec heroes and had gelblum
tchèque blum et le président de
l'eurogroupe
et puis également avec le président du
directoire de la deutsche bank
plusieurs dirigeants économiques
participeront à l'événement est
évidemment pour nicolas sarkozy au
moment où il déjeunera avec la
chancelière sera le moment de rappeler
l'importance centrale du moteur
franco-allemand qui est indispensable au
bon fonctionnement de l'union et ce
moteur
comme vous le savez ne fonctionne pas
très bien aujourd'hui puisqu'on entend
pas le président de la république
françois hollande sur les débats
européens nous parlerons du brics tout à
l'heure où la france brille par son très
grand silence et quand nous serons
revenus aux affaires ça sera notre
responsabilité politique à nous les
républicains de relancer ce moteur
franco allemand
puisque sans ce moteur franco-allemand
en réalité l'europe ne fonctionne pas
quand vous avez un bateau qui est dirigé
par 28 personnes
vous avez du mal à éviter les icebergs
et donc il faut qu' il faut une unité de
commandement et l'unité de commandement
cette unité aller franco allemande où
elle n'est pas voilà pour l'agenda
venons en à quelques points de fond nous
voulons d'abord redire avec une certaine
gravité
la très grande préoccupation des
républicains face à l'état de désordre
dans lequel notre pays s'enfonce mois
après mois
semaine après semaine jour après jour
s'agissant d'abord de la menace
terroriste islamiste
elle était extrêmement élevé nous le
savons le chef de l'état et le chef du
gouvernement
le répète jour après jour l'attentât
sauvage l'assassinât sauvage dont deux
policiers ont été victimes la semaine
dernière doit appeler les autorités de
l'état rattrapé de toute urgence le
retard qui a été pris nous n'acceptons
pas que des individus connus des
services de renseignement parfois déjà
condamné par la justice soient libres de
leurs mouvements sans aucune
surveillance effectivement opérationnel
et donc nous appelons le gouvernement à
mettre hors d'état de nuire ces
individus qui veulent nous détruire
c'est la raison pour laquelle de
continuer au parlement et notamment à
l'assemblée nationale à faire un certain
nombre de propositions
christian jacob le président du groupe
l'est républicain de l'assemblée
nationale sera d'ailleurs reçu à
matignon avec un certain nombre de
députés au cours de la de la semaine
nous sommes une initiative nous faisons
des propositions
nous voulons que le gouvernement les
ententes ce qui est en jeu c'est
évidemment l'intérêt l'intérêt national
s'agissant des manifestations second
point nous appelons le gouvernement à
sortir de son inertie
c'est au gouvernement de gouverner ce
n'est pas au gouvernement de commenter
ce n'est pas au gouvernement d'envisager
cette gouvernement de gouverner et donc
il appartient désormais au gouvernement
d'interdire les manifestations qui sont
susceptibles de dégénérer et
d'occasionner de très graves troubles à
l'ordre public on l'a vu hélas la
semaine dernière mardi dernier
cette manifestation organisée par la cgt
a occasionné vous le savez 40 blessés
l'agression absolument scandaleuse et
invraisemblable dont a été victime
l'hôpital necker au moment même où il
séjournait ce petit enfant orphelin
puisque ses sept enfants hospitalisés à
necker
au moment même où les agresseurs s'en
prenait cet hôpital
les l'extrême violence des des casseurs
tout ça doit appeler une réponse
extrêmement ferme alors aujourd'hui ici
au nom des républicains je voudrais
adresser un carton rouge à monsieur
martinez le leader de la cgt et un
carton jaune au premier ministre manuel
valls qui ne gère pas comme il devrait
gérer cette situation donc très
concrètement nous appelons à
l'interdiction de la manifestation
prévue jeudi
il faut pas attendre que le lait soit
renversée pour pour pleurer un faux pas
tendre jeudi soir pour constater des
débordements il faut anticiper cette
manifestation ne doit pas se tenir dans
les conditions que nous connaissons
j'ajoute que les policiers des forces
mobiles et les gendarmes des escadrons
mobiles sont extrêmement sollicités par
les divers événements vous connaissez et
notamment aussi par la coupe d'europe
des nations par l'euro 2016 bref dans ce
contexte l'interdiction de la
manifestation de jeudi nous paraît tout
à fait nécessaire le contexte
d'application de la loi sur l'état
d'urgence ne doit pas être virtuel ça ne
veut pas dire naturellement qu'il faille
interdire toutes les manifestations tout
le temps de manière générale et absolue
ça n'est pas cela notre ordre juridique
mais au cas particulier compte tenu des
très graves risques de débordements qui
pèsent sur cette manifestation nous
appelons gouvernement à prendre ses
responsabilités à agir et donc à
interdire cette manifestation prévue
jeudi
j'ajoute que toutes les procédures
juridiques doivent être appliquées
conformément à la loi et notamment le
principe de responsabilité quiconque ose
un dommage en doit réparation c'est dans
le code civil depuis 1800 et quelques
1804 je crois il faut donc que la
responsabilité
ville de la cgt soit engagée de manière
effective
bien évidemment pour réparer les dégâts
occasionnés par les troubles suscités
par sept organisations syndicales
minoritaires qui trouve désormais
gravement l'ordre public dans notre pays
merci sur les questions de la question
sur le bric site qui est évidemment
l'actualité européenne brûlante
donc je ne commenterai pas les sondages
qui sont évidemment qui montre que la
situation est extrêmement extrêmement
tendue la campagne comme vous le savez a
été endeuillée par le décès l'assassinât
de la députée britannique travailliste
john cox le président de notre mouvement
exprimé l'émotion de notre famille
politique le débat politique est d'une
très grande violence en europe et on
voit où au fond les campagnes populiste
qui font appel au sentiment est plus à
la raison peuvent conduire
je ne veux pas dire évidemment par la
queue l'assassinât est liée à des
déclarations directement des
responsables politiques britanniques qui
sont engagés dans le débat en faveur du
mexique
toutefois tous les commentateurs ont
observé que les débats étaient d'une
violence absolue et quand vous ne mettez
plus de limites au débat politique en
permettant toutes les outrances verbales
et bien il ya un certain nombre
d'esprits faible qui peuvent être amenés
à
à commettre les actes dramatiques que
nous commentons sur le break site
lui-même ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que
d'abord première membres excite ou pas
il faudra refonder l'europe que les
angles que les britanniques restent où
ne restent pas ce dont l'europe a besoin
c'est de dialogue politique ce dont
l'europe a besoin c'est d'un
gouvernement économique et non plus
d'une gestion bureaucratique et cette
gestion bureaucratique c'est ça dont les
européens qu'ils soient britanniques ou
français ou autre c'est pareil en
allemagne c'est pareil en italie ou en
grèce
et bien cette gestion bureaucratique
nous n'en voulons plus et cela passe par
des institutions renouvelée et des
institutions démocratiques et donc il
est assez intéressant de voir que
finalement c'est le royaume uni qui va
nous permettre de mettre sur la table ce
débat et le président de notre mouvement
a très clairement dit les choses quand
nous reviendrons au pouvoir dans le mois
qui suivra l'élection présidentielle
nous déposerons sur le bureau du conseil
une proposition de nouveau traité qui
tirera les leçons du débat actuel sur le
break site
d'ailleurs la passion qu'ont les
opinions publiques européennes
dans ce débat des montres absolument là
la nécessité de réinjecter de la
politique et d'ouverture d'un tel débat
ça c'est le premier point le deuxième
point c'est que nous sommes frappés par
l'absence totale des vocations même de
la question du bric site par nos
gouvernants à nou camp la grande
bretagne est entrée dans l'union
à l'époque la communauté européenne il y
a eu plusieurs années de débats français
le général de gaulle lisez l'histoire
mettait cette question du royaume uni
dans le débat français
cela faisait partie des débats que nous
avions entre nous entre la droite et la
gauche et le centre aujourd'hui où est
le débat politique
quelle est la position du gouvernement
français sur le bric site il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui de position du gouvernement
français assure le président
la seule déclaration qui a été faite par
françois hollande ça paraît tellement
gaguesque mais j'ai vérifié c'est
françois hollande a pris position sur le
break site dans un tunnel
en suisse il a inauguré un tunnel en
suisse et c'est dans le tunnel en suisse
qu'il a évoqué le break site en disant
que ce serait une très mauvaise chose
le décalage entre la réalité et la
gravité surtout des choses et et cédé
son absence de déclaration si ce n'est
dans ce tunnel s'est inaugurée le 8 juin
le tunnel du gothard et il a dit nous
sommes unis comme nous ne l'avons jamais
été et j'espère que les britanniques
s'en souviendront le jour venu nous
trouvons que la force de cette
déclaration est absolument
extraordinaire
mais évidemment totalement stupéfiants
par rapport à la gravité des choses
puisque nous pensons républicain que la
sortie du royaume uni de l'union serait
un grave problème à la fois pour l'union
et la france et sera évidemment un grave
problème pour le royaume-uni lui-même
mais nous souhaiterions savoir quel est
le plan b
que se passe-t-il le lendemain le
lendemain de l'élection en grande
bretagne que les grands bretons et
choisit de rester ou pas que veulent que
veut le gouvernement français qu'est ce
qu'il va dire
nous aimerions connaître le plan b nous
craignons qu'il n'y a pas de plan b
et c'est vraiment une source de très
grandes inquiétudes
demain madame merkel des jeunes avec
nicolas sarkozy et à françois hollande
la question c'est que l'europe est en
danger et où est le président de la
république française eh bien il est soit
dans un tunnel en suisse ou à paris mais
il ne discute pas avec la chancelière et
sa position n'est pas n'est pas connu
quant à la position du premier ministre
est celle du ministre des affaires
étrangères je ne parle pas du ministre
délégué aux affaires européennes
elle est totalement inexistante donc
nous sommes face à une situation d'une
extrême gravité
alors vous savez que ce qui va se passer
c'est que le lendemain
le lendemain ou le surlendemain
peut-être convoquer un conseil si jamais
les britanniques décidé de sortir et ce
conseil va lancer une procédure si les
britanniques décident de sortir qui
devrait aboutir dans les deux années
avec une situation intermédiaire qui là
aussi est totalement inconnu nous
aurions aimé savoir la position de la
france pas l'hypothèse d'un break site
sûr que deviennent par exemple et député
européen britannique continue-t-il à
pouvoir voter
j'aimerais connaître la position de la
france nous républicains nous
considérons que si le divorce a lieu les
députés européens britanniques doivent
cesser de voter au parlement européen
mais juridiquement la sphère pas clair
nous aimerions des positions claires de
la france nous aimerions savoir ce que
la france pense du fait que c'est le
royaume uni qui va présider le conseil
dans un an en juillet 2017 alors que
nous serions dans les deux ans de
période intermédiaire de sortie quelle
est la position de la france est elle la
france est elle d'accord sur une
présidence du royaume uni d'un conseil
alors qu'il serait sur une position de
sortie pas vous comprenez que le sujet
est vraiment d'une très grande gravité
et que la politique de la chaise vide en
l'occurrence n'est vraiment pas la bonne
sur la question du bric site j'en ai
terminé tout oui à un mot sur la turquie
puisqu'il ya un feuilleton turc vous
savez ici en europe en réalité quelle
est la nouveauté le 15 juin la
commission européenne a publié un
document donc qui n'est pas passée
inaperçue chez nous le document c'est
quoi et bien la commission européenne a
publié un document sur l'état des
négociations concernant la
libéralisation des visas puisque vous
savez que ça fait partie de l'accord les
turcs devraient pouvoir bénéficier de
vise à libéraliser pour entrer librement
dans l'union
si l'europe leur donne donne cet accord
à nous aux républicains nous sommes
évidemment opposés à cette
libéralisation des visas et la
commission européenne a établi la chose
suivante elle a rappelé que sur 72
critères nécessaires que la turquie doit
remplir pour que les visas pour l'heure
ses ressortissants soient libéralisé 67
sur 72 sont remplies ça c'est la
position au 15 juin
les critères qui ne sont pas remplies
sont des critères assez dur
il manque une loi sur la protection des
données il manque une loi sur une
définition du terrorisme
les turcs n'ont pas la même position la
définition que nous on voit bien
pourquoi la question kurde est
évidemment au coeur des débats
et puis accessoirement la libéralisation
des visas n'est possible que en cas de
possession d'un visa d'un visa
commanditant biométrique d'un passeport
biométrique
vous pouvez obtenir un visa libre que si
vous avez un passeport biométrique ceux
dont la plupart des turcs sont dépourvus
notre crainte est la suivante c'est que
le 4 mars 2016 la commission européenne
c'était avant l'accord faisait savoir
que la turquie remplissait 19 critères
sur 72 et par miracle
nous sommes désormais à 67 sur 72 on
l'avait entendu il ya trois semaines ça
a été confirmé par le document du 15
juin de la commission européenne et nous
considérons que le passage miraculeux 19
à 67 est en fait le fruit d'une dune une
acrobatie juridique de la part de la
commission sur ordre de angela merkel et
là aussi nous aurions aimé que la france
puisse se prononcer contre cette
libéralisation des visas suite épisodes
suivants à la rentrée nous saurons si la
turquie remplit les derniers critères
qui lui permettront passé de 67 à 72
nous pensions qu'ils ne seront pas
remplies mais nous craignons que
juridiquement la commission affirment
qu'ils le soient merci je voudrais
maintenant aborder deux questions de
société qui ont une certaine importance
pour nous et une importance certaine
plus exactement dans cette atmosphère de
fin de règne qui caractérise cette
dernière année du quinquennat de
françois hollande et sept dernières
années de la mandature à l'assemblée
nationale
un certain nombre de mesures subreptice
qui nous préoccupe beaucoup et sur
lesquels nous nous voulons appeler votre
attention l'attention de l'attention des
médias et l'attention l'attention des
français première mort la semaine
dernière à la commission des affaires
sociales de l'assemblée nationale a été
adoptée pardon c'est pas la commission
des affaires sociales c'est une
commission spéciale peu importe a été
adopté en commission un amendement du
gouvernement présenté par najat vallaud
belkacem
c'est très précisément l'amendement
numéro 8 153 au projet de loi sur
l'égalité et la citoyenneté
c'est un amendement très important passé
complètement inaperçu
pour l'instant cet amendement il donne
au gouvernement le pouvoir
par ordonnance de modifier
considérablement le régime des écoles
libres nous ici les républicains nous
défendons l'école libre menacé par le
gouvernement socialiste en général et
par najat vallaud-belkacem en
particulier cet amendement je le tiens à
votre disposition permettrait donc au
gouvernement par ordonnance de modifier
les dispositions législatives du code de
l'éducation relative aux établissements
privés d'enseignement scolaire afin je
cite l'amendement de remplacer les
régimes de déclaration d'ouverture
préalable en vigueur par un régime
d'autorisation donc on passerait d'un
régime de liberté de liberté contrôler
qui consiste lorsqu'on crée un
établissement scolaire privé à le
déclarer un régime d'autorisation
d'autorisation etc sentait avant
l'ouverture qui n'est pas un régime de
liberté évidemment puisque c'est
précisément un régime d'autorisation par
définition le champ de cette
habilitation est extrêmement large et
nous préoccupe beaucoup
s'il faut un débat sur ces questions là
c'est vraiment au parlement qu'il faut
l'avoir pas par ordonnance qu une telle
question doit être abordée ya un
problème de forme
et puis surtout sur le fond je les dis
j'ai un petit la semaine dernière lors
du point presse je le répète avec
certaine solennité parce que c'est un
vrai sujet c'est un sujet vraiment de
fond qui est traité comme ça à la
va-vite au détour d'un amendement
quittant le gouvernement à prendre des
dispositions majeures pas ordonnance
mais c'est un vrai sujet de fond nous
pensons que ce régime de liberté
d'enseignement doit être préservée doit
pas être remplacé par un régime
d'autorisation ça ne veut pas dire que
le gouvernement l'autorité publique
l'administration de ne faire aucun
contrôle d'aucune nature sur les
établissements d'enseignement scolaire
libre naturellement y compris les
enseignements s'agissant du contenu des
enseignements s'agissant aussi de
l'ordre public il faut que encore le
gouvernement gouverne opèrent les
contrôles qui doivent être faits la loi
lui en donne aujourd'hui la possibilité
même le devoir y compris dans le code
pénal on peut faire fermer un
établissement hors contrat
s'il ya des troubles à l'ordre public si
le contenu dans l'enseignement n'est pas
correct bref il faut que le gouvernement
utilise les outils actuels de la loi
mais cette modification très importantes
du régime des écoles libres nous la
combattons nous y voyons un recul des
libertés il faudra que najat vallaud
belkacem s'en explique de manière plus
plus claire de manière plus ouverte ni
sur la forme
l' ordonnance ni sur le fond nous ne
sommes en accord encore une fois nous
pensons que l'école libre aujourd'hui
est menacé par par le parti socialiste
il nous appartient de sonnets de saône l
alerte deuxième second plutôt sujet
relatives aux questions de société que
je souhaite aborder avec vous ce matin
la gpa la gestation pour autrui
il y aura demain un vote important à
l'assemblée nationale sur une
proposition de loi présentée par le
groupe républicain est rapportée par
valérie boyer
ça n'est pas un sujet secondaire
les républicains ont fait un vrai
travail de fond avec valérie boyer pour
donner toute sa portée en droit interne
à l'interdiction de la gpa la gpa
aujourd'hui elle est interdite même une
interdiction d'ordre public mais pour
donner toute sa portée à cette
interdiction
nous avons proposé d'une part de
réprimer plus fortement les actes commis
par des intermédiaires
d'autre part et surtout nous proposons
que cette interdiction et ses
conséquences pénales et un caractère
d'extraterritorialité pour le dire
autrement le français qui auraient
recours à la gpa dans un pays étranger
serait en vertu de cette proposition de
loi punit en france
comme s'ils avaient eu recours à la gpa
en français donc on voit bien qu'on est
au coeur du sujet puisque la gpa est
interdite en france elle n'est pas
interdite dans un certain nombre de pays
européens notamment et ça suscite
beaucoup de beaucoup de détournements
donc un texte très pratique très
opérationnelle qui a été travaillé par
les députés républicains qui a été
présenté jeudi dernier dans des
conditions tout à fait singulière
puisque les députés socialistes ont pas
daigné se déplacer
cet après midi du jeudi il n'y avait un
moment plus qu'un seul député socialiste
en séance le gouvernement était donc en
minorité il ya une réserve de vote
bref encore une fois le gouvernement
était en difficulté mais indépendamment
de la forme sur le fond il ya un vrai
sujet et donc demain il y aura un
instant de vérité
les masques tombent on peut pas comme le
font certaines autorités
gouvernementales dire on est opposé à la
gpa et ne prendre aucune mesure
opérationnel pour donner à cette
interdiction sa porte est et donc c'est
un vote demain qui de notre point de vue
une vraie importance pour bien
identifier qui pratiquent le double
langage en l'occurrence le parti
socialiste et qui les républicains
décident de lutter activement contre la
gp11 nous luttant activement contre la
gpa pour une raison de fond c'est
évidemment la dignité de la personne
humaine
la dignité des femmes dont le ventre ne
saurait faire l'objet d'une location la
dignité des enfants qui ne sont pas une
marchandise sur laquelle un contrat
pourrait être pour être préparée il ya
un sujet de fond absolument majeur nous
avons été nombreux dans l'hémicycle à
nous exprimer notamment le professeur
leonetti dont on connaît la densité de
la réflexion sur les sur les questions
éthiques
voilà donc c'est un vote de mam qui pour
nous avons une vraie importance parce
que c'est un texte opérationnel parce
que l'opposition a été une nouvelle fois
force de proposition et parce que la
majorité socialiste est extrêmement
ambiguë c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
sur cette question essentielle
je reviens sur une actualité européenne
mais européano française s'est en tout
cas qui nous concerne vraiment au
premier chef
c'est la question de la réglementation
sur les armes à feu
la commission européenne a décidé de
proposer après les attentats de paris
une nouvelle disposition législative qui
réglemente les armes à feu et qui vise à
à
non pas interdire il est déjà mais à
être plus efficaces quant à la lutte
contre le trafic des armes automatiques
et semi automatique ça il ya des tas de
pays de l'est de l'europe y compris dans
l'union où circulent beaucoup d'armes de
guerre ou d'armes qui ont été inactivé
puis réactivé et l'union européenne
et parfois un peu inefficace dans cette
lutte contre contre ces trafics et donc
le texte nous a été proposé par la
commission et les députés des
républicains honte amender ce texte qui
n'est pas encore votée mais nous voulons
dire deux choses la première le premier
point c'est qu'évidemment nous voulons
lutter contre ces trafics d'armes de
guerre nous parlons bien d'armes de
guerre je veux pas que les kalachnikovs
circulent en europe il faut pas qu'elle
puisse être vendu par internet par
exemple y compris si elles ont été
démilitarisée parce qu'elles peuvent
être re militarisé ensuite il faut pas
par exemple que les gens puissent payer
en liquide les armes à feu ce qui est
aujourd'hui le cas c'est aujourd'hui
possible
donc tout cela nous voulons interdire
mais en même temps nous ne voulons pas
d'une loi qui se tromperait de cible et
qui ciblerait les chasseurs par exemple
et les tireurs sportifs les chasseurs ne
sont pas des terroristes et on n'a
jamais vu de terroristes passer son
permis de chasser donc la question n'est
pas du tout là or le texte de la
commission mélanger un peu tout et
finalement créer des conditions qui
arrivait à faire en sorte que désormais
les chasseurs puissent être fiché à la
même hauteur que le sont les possesseurs
potentielle d'armes de guerre désactiver
ce qui est évidemment inimaginable donc
ne pas confondre évidemment les débats
ne pas créer une usine administratives
qui ne donnerait que les bons citoyens
et qui ne gênerait en rien les
terroristes donc les républicains sont
en train de travailler sur ce texte nous
y reviendrons quand le texte fera
avancer dans la fabrique législatives
européennes
merci j'ajoute que cette question de la
chasse sera aussi beaucoup débattu cette
semaine à l'assemblée est ce que vous
avez le projet de loi sur la
biodiversité qui revient et c'est david
douillet d'ailleurs pour les
républicains qui mènera la bataille en
faveur de la liberté des chasseurs un
dernier mot je sens que votre attention
recul lorsque nous avons été peut-être
un peu plus long que d'habitude vous
aurez noté le caractère très structurée
du point presse
non plus sérieusement je voudrais dire
un mot de ce qui fait l'actualité de la
gauche puisque naturellement nous lisons
la presse des pêches après dépêche
article après article
nous essayons modestement de nous tenir
informés les épisodes extrêmement
nombreux non pas de ce feuilleton mais
de cette série saison 1 saison 2 saison
3 saison 4 de la primaire des gauches
alors manifestement ça prend beaucoup de
temps au président de la république qui
en oublient peut-être de gouverner nous
avons le sentiment ici que l'ipo
président de la république est plus que
jamais lipper secrétaire du parti
socialiste
on valide hypo président hyper
secrétaire du parti socialiste
c'est quand même la première fois dans
l'histoire de la vème république ce sera
au moins un record
j'ai le record d'impopularité mais c'est
la première fois dans l'histoire d'un
cinquième république que le président
sortant est à ce point perçus à ce point
pardon peu perçu comme le candidat
naturel de son camp qui doivent
organiser lui-même une primaire pour
tenter de se re légitimer aux yeux des
militants de son propre de son propre
parti brice hortefeux disait ce matin
qu' il n'était pas un candidat naturel
qu'il était sans doute un candidat
contre
contre nature chefs d'état amateurs il
est en revanche un animateur
professionnel des différents courants de
la gauche
et tout ça nous afflige évidemment parce
qu'on a le sentiment que pendant que le
président de la république regarde le
nombril de la gauche est bien les
grandes affaires les grands sujets qu'on
a évoqué tout au long de ce point presse
la situation européenne la dislocation
possible de l'union européenne hélas
avec le avec le break site
les désordres publics tragiques que vit
veut nos compatriotes tous ces sujets de
fond sont comme passaient au second plan
de l'agenda présidentiel puisque ce sont
les questions partisanes qui semble être
passé chez lui au premier plan de
l'agenda lorsqu'on passe au second temps
de ce point presse et donc secrétaire
général des républicains eric woerth et
le député maire d'arcachon yves foulon
secrétaire national au tourisme vont
vous parler de ce qu'ils veulent en fait
mais notamment du tourisme je crois en
fait vous en rêviez on va le faire on va
vous parler juste avant les vacances de
tourisme
il foule on a travaillé de façon
extrêmement extrême une façon d'en c'est
avec beaucoup d équipes donc on
souhaitait pouvoir n'a pas eu le temps
de faire une convention sur le tourisme
pour plein de plein de raisons mais
évidemment dans cette dernière phase de
projet on voulait mettre un petit coup
de projecteur avant l'été sur cette
industrie qu'est le tourisme industrie
tellement importante pour la pour la
france je passe tout de suite la parole
à yves merci eric oui effectivement
après cette conférence de presse
importante
on voulait vous parler d'un sujet qui
est néanmoins important parce que le
tourisme c'est 86 millions de visiteurs
par an nous sommes la première
destination du monde
france 3 millions et demi d'emplois qui
sont générés par cette activité faut que
vous sachez aussi que le tourisme c'est
8% du pib c'est à dire c'est plus
important que l'industrie automobile et
les sujets sur lequel nous nous sommes
penchés quand nicolas sarkozy m'a confié
le scrutin national au tourisme sous
l'autorité d'eric woerth qui gère
l'ensemble du projet les républicains
c'était d'apporter des solutions bien
sûr en terme d'emploi parce que le
tourisme doit générer plus d'emplois
qu'aujourd'hui et c'est un enjeu que
nous avons exploré et le deuxième enjeu
c'est partant d'un d'un constat
extrêmement simple c'est que en france
un touriste génère à peu près par
personne 650 euros lors de sa visite sur
notre territoire en espagne et italie
qui sont les deux autres pays très fort
en europe sur le plan touristique
il génère un touriste 1000 euros lors de
sa visite dans ces deux pays et aux
états unis où le président américain a
fait une grande cause nationale d'une
nouvelle politique touristique
le touriste génère aux usa 2200 euros
donc ça veut dire que l'enjeu c'était de
trouver des solutions en termes
d'emplois et le deuxième enjeu c'était
de trouver des solutions en termes de
recettes concrètes pour nos
entrepreneurs mais également pour l'état
français alors une série de propositions
et après nous répondrons à vos questions
si vous le souhaitez un sujet qui a été
commun à tous les experts que nous avons
consultés et il y en a parmi nous
quelques-uns qui sont ici jean burtin
que le président de l'office tourisme de
france et puis jacques augustin qui est
un consultant bien connu le premier
sujet c'est la gouvernance en matière de
tourisme qui a été évoqué nous avons
souhaité qu'il y ait plus de
transversalité et pour ce faire nous
proposons qu'il y ait un ministre qui
rendent compte directement au premier
ministre avec par là même une
mutualisation des moyens qui doivent
être données dans le cas de la nouvelle
politique touristique à partir de 2017
si les français nous font confiance
le deuxième volet dit
proposition très concrète c'est une
réforme de l'un de l'organisation des
compétences chacun dans le passé a pu
voir que le tourisme était un coup
attribué au département un coup
attribués aux régions voyez dans la loi
de l'autre dernièrement le gouvernement
a proposé que les offices de tourisme
qui aujourd'hui sont gérées par les
communes soient transférés aux
intercommunalités
tout ça ne satisfait personne et surtout
pas une majorité d'acteurs dû tourisme
dont nous nous préférons ont proposé
qu'il y ait un principe de liberté et
l'un ou des collectivités souhaiteront
s'engager dans une politique touristique
innovante avec des moyens qui seront
attribués par la collectivité elle
pourra le faire dans les conditions
qu'elle souhaite avec bien sûr l'idée et
c'est important que la promotion
internationale de la destination france
soit maîtrisé par l'état au travers
d'une agence française qui a une
vocation mondiale
troisième sujet très précis et qui est
totalement novateur qui a été mis en
oeuvre aux états unis notamment c'est ce
qu'on appelle les projets d'intérêt
touristiques qui pourront être proposés
par toutes les collectivités chacune
dans sa strate avec une combinaison
d'acteurs publics d'acteurs publics et
privés ou d'atr que privés qui pourront
faire des propositions et être
accompagné par l'état français
quatrième volet de notre travail c'est
une réponse à ce qu'on appelle la
nouvelle technologie internet l'économie
collaborative qu'on connaît bien
vous entendez parler d'un bienne be des
plateformes de location qui aujourd'hui
présente une difficulté majeure pour les
entrepreneurs hôteliers restaurateurs
mais qui donne une belle image pour les
utilisateurs que sont l'ensemble des
français donc nous proposons deux pour
les activités des particuliers de créer
une dynamique sur le statut d'auto
entrepreneur c'est qu'il ya une
limitation à la recettes encaissées dans
les prestations de services et 30000
euros par an
ça permettrait de trouver un principe d'
équilibre entre les entrepreneurs
hôteliers restaurateurs qui ont à leur
charge toutes les taxes diverses les
impôts mais aussi toutes les normes et
en même temps de laisser libre cours à
l'économie collaborative de se faire de
l'argent comme l'on dit quand on est
particulier en utilisant les plateformes
que l'on connaît bien
un autre volet c'est la formation bien
sûr avec le métier du tourisme qui doit
être reconnue encadré nous proposons une
unité d'application des métiers du
tourisme aux étudiants français et
européen avec un site pilote sur le
territoire national ou ultra marins nous
apportons des réponses aux phénomènes
d'insécurité que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui on voit bien en ce moment
même au travers de l'euro que l'addition
à des manifestations diverses et variées
des attentats qui ont eu lieu sur le
territoire national nous fragilise et
donc nous apportons une réponse par un
centre d'appel spécialisé avec un numéro
dédié qui sera destination évidemment
des visiteurs étrangers avec multi
langues bien sûr qui sera de nature à
rassurer les visiteurs potentiels
étrangers
un autre volet sur lequel nous apportons
une réponse et le tourisme associatif à
vocation sociale le chèque vacances
n'est plus un dispositif cohérent et
suffisant dont nous proposons de mettre
en place un certain nombre
d'alternatives et enfin dernier point ce
dont souffrent nos entrepreneurs du
tourisme comme les entrepreneurs
français au sens large c'est l'addition
de normes et de fiscalité en tout genre
bien sûr des propositions seront faites
globalement dans le projet économique
fiscal des républicains nous nous y
associons pour considérer que les
acteurs du tourisme doivent bénéficier
de normes moins lourde qui les empêchent
de prendre des initiatives et également
d'une fiscalité qui soit moins
pénalisante
voilà chers amis ce que
eric sous son autorité nous avons
répondu qui peut maintenant être insérée
dans le volet général de notre projet
des républicains est un prêt sur le
numérique quand même sur tout ce qui
concerne airbnb etc
il faut évidemment qui est une une
loyauté évidemment chacun emploie ce
type de mécanisme tous à tous et dans le
temps mais enfin on a des systèmes
d'hôtellerie et de restauration qui est
extrêmement important et notamment
d'hôtellerie soumis à des normes parce
qu'elle n'est pas le cas de cécité
soumis aussi une fiscalité qui souvent
n'est pas le cas de cécile donc à la
volonté absolue d'une loyauté économique
qui devra prendre beaucoup de formes
on le voit aujourd'hui dans le domaine
la taxe de séjour mais ça va plus loin
que la taxe de séjour donc c'est un
sujet sur lequel on sera
particulièrement vigilant ce pas une
économie contre une autre